So we want to do efficient exploration
in general stochastic MDPs.
And so we're going to need to combine
the two ideas that we've been
talking about.
>> Wait, what were the two
ideas we were talking about?
>> Well in the context of bandits,
we talked about stochastic processes.
And the trick that we used was to use
something like a Hoeffding bound.
We just keep repeating the stochastic
thing until we have enough data, so
that we can make accurate estimates.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And then we talked about
sequential domains
that are deterministic.
And the main trick that we used there
was this r max trick that said,
if there's a state action pair
that we don't know about,
assume it's really, really good.
>> Okay.
>> We can put these two ideas together
and get a stochastic version of Rmax.
>> Okay, so
we'll have Hoeffding regions.
>> Yes.
Good, good, good.
>> [LAUGH] We're still going to use
Hoeffding bounds on the individual state
action pairs.
>> Okay.
>> In fact, regions probably
means state action pairs here.
>> So I was right.
>> Yes, you were right.
>> Good.
Well, then I think we're done here.
>> All right, so let's write down
what this algorithm looks like.